好 这一次大家都知道
除了我们跟着美股走之外
韩国的纷纷扰扰
也是让我们上了一课
从来没看过
韩国人真的好辛苦
都已经走上街头了
但是昨天晚上记忆体涨
今天三星海力士涨
是那种20% 30%的涨
太惊人了
所以来看一下
这边请到我们报价天王
昨天他叫韩神救援
海力士的会长崔泰元
他投了1亿
这个1亿台币左右
竟然让大家的市值
共同增加将近11兆
记忆体的修正是不是结束了
再来被动今天好不容易
从绿灯变刷一排红灯
是不是估值也杀完了
好来我们来看一下
其实最近期货市场
外资还是主要以空单为主
那我觉得这个本来就是
他们常用的一个避险手段
所以这一波其实像昨天
这个富台期结算
如果刚好有避险空单
其实他就有压在一个相对低
那只是说赏物的围台
目前还是说台湾人蛮有钱的
这个不屈不老
现在其实都还是偏多
那当然今天赚了
对就是重点是你保证金要够
有撑过去前两天
这是一个目前的状况
好 再来记忆体的部分
这个SK的一个会长
那昨天他花了大概1亿台币
那买了自家公司的补票
其实1亿台币对一个
这么大集团公司来说
真的是这个九牛一毛
不過我覺得它時間點
挑得滿好的
剛好就是挑在
這個所謂韓國的散戶
基本上台灣叫割韭菜
我就開玩笑講
韓國可能是叫割泡菜
泡菜被割完之後
而且它7月31號
你很有創意
很有創意 還好啦
因為7月31號
因為之前杠杆型ETF太瘋狂了
所以他們政府也在7月31號
加了很多到緊箍咒
就是过去的这个入场的保证金呢
我没记错的话要提高三倍
然后呢买的股数
以前比如说假设可以买一股
现在最少要买20股
就是你三成为20
就是你要进场的条件
它一下子就拉高了30倍到60倍
就是不要说再让很多
这个小散户进来市场乱玩
到时候输钱又很紧张这样
好那摩根大空前两天也发了一个报告
说杠杆已经去尾声了
避险基金也90%去掉杠杆
所以昨天所有的这个机体呢
都大涨
那除了台湾的韭菜被割完
韩国的泡菜被割完之外呢
昨天呢美国
我们不知道他叫什么菜
叫他大头菜好了
美国的大头菜也被割了
那这个是一个年轻人
他其实才24岁而已
24岁的少年股神
对可以说是一个天才
这个操盘手
那他其实今年上半年的这个
这个绩效是好到吓死人了
400多%
很厉害啊
到6月为止400%
因为它都重压AI股
而且呢
照之前这个市场的一个估计
它大概开了三到四倍的杠杆
三到四倍的杠杆
所以它的绩效才会这么惊人
而且呢有人帮它算过
如果从它基金
大概这两年就是从AI开始
这两年进来
其实它的整体绩效高达100%
不是100%是100倍
100倍
对100倍有人帮它算过了
就是这两年
因为它是杠杆开很大
而且从两三年前
刚好AI开始的时候
它就中业了
哇 一百倍
但是呢
即便再怎么省有
一个月也挂掉了
为什么因为它杠杆开太大
因为有人去算过
这个是以它Q1公布的持股来说
当然后面
后面陆陆续续有人看它
到底最新什么股票
其实基本上都是全部
甚至海力士在美国挂牌的
它都有去认
所以它其实这波
基本上全部都是中压高科技股
然后以它低级的这些持股来看這一波平均平均都回檔三成以上那你要想它是三到四倍的槓桿那基本上就是掛掉了它就是跟某一家避險基金談好
然後整包就是
可能對折再對折賣給它
那這個消息一出來之後
美股昨天全面大漲
因為市場都在想要割一個大的
對 最大顆的已經被割走了
最大顆的那個槓桿已經被割走
所以就很現實
就是台灣的韭菜
韓國的泡菜
我的大頭彩
都是一樣的
好 那包括我們的這個之前
投信投顧公衛的會長張錫
那他認為說台積電
現在是甜甜價
因為這一次最低
大概就殺到2200
那他的看法是這樣
明年2027年
EPS上刊140塊
2028到2029年
樂觀挑戰200塊
那我給大家一個觀念就是
你看任何的報導
其實你不能說照單全收
他講140就140
他講200就200
不是 而是你要
再多去参考一些资料
然后呢
根据你手中的一些资料
再去做更进一步的分析
那这个部分呢
我就教大家怎么做
他刚刚讲的是明年嘛
明年的话
他的版本是140嘛
你把这个2027年
各家估的抓出来的话
确实是落在这个区间没有错
保守版的可能大概130出头
乐观版的呢
有到接近160
所以他讲的140
确实是一个比较中性
就是你把这些加加减减出来之后
可能大概是140左右
是差不多的
比如说我们就一个保守版的好了
它是中性版
我用保守版来去看
如果说是这个17或18倍的话呢
其实用17倍去算
其实大概2200是差不多的
所以它为什么说2200很便宜
原因就在这里
那大家去看
如果你要估计它的话呢
你要看我这边两个
这个圈圈圈起来
其实就是浅蓝色的这个区块
就是你可以发现
红色它是它的股价嘛
红色是股价
然后这个浅蓝色的区块
大概就在这里
17左右
16.7倍嘛
所以如果当年度台积电的业绩
跟获利是成长的话
可能大概18 17倍以下
你就可以开始慢慢买
为什么我比较喜欢
就是有法人在追踪的大股票
就是你可以找到很多资料来做对比
因为小股票的原因
因为这波很多大跌的小股票
就是之前大家太乐观
可是问题是你又没有估过它的EPS
你也不知道说合理的区间在哪
所以这种大股票
是蛮适合用这种方式去估的
好 再来
那鸿海一样 你去看
今年大概大家估17 18块
乐观一点的到19块都有
明年大概普遍就是都20块起跳
那鸿海的方式一样
你去估
如果明年可以20块
那它的本利比区间
你看大概就是会打到
这个两个蓝色之间
两个蓝色大概就在这里
11.5到13.4
那你取个中间值
maybe就是大概12倍吧
或12.5倍
12.5倍
那这一次呢
这个鸿海最低
大概刹到230块
你用这样去算的话
其实确实它也是回落到
一个合理的本利比区间
所以今天鸿海也是突然间大涨
原因就在这里
那你都可以一样化
台积电也好 鸿海都是大股票
所以法人的报告
你可以找到蛮多的来去做一个比较
好 再来
这次简单给大家一个
这个目前盘式的看法
因为今天所有的股票都大涨
很多政治一开盘都跳空涨停
所以之后会不会涨
还是要看产业跟个别公司的成长性
那很多人觉得说
那既然是这样的话
是不是要马上开始再进场
因为之前可能高档买的
现在赔30 40%
是不是加码去摊品
我个人是觉得说
投资的一个大原则是这样子
不去加码摊品
目前赔钱中的股票
那当然会觉得说
那你觉得后面会上
我现在加码不好吗
其实我觉得这是一个原则的问题
如果是这样的情况之下
我宁可你再去找
是不是有在这波下跌的过程里面
更杀到物超所值的股票
你去买
我觉得这样会比较好
然后再来就是我们刚前面
跟大家讲过的
你要去了解金银两银的获利跟EPS至少你要能够抓出一个大概的区间不是说你去算一定可以算到精确的数字而是你要可以抓出一个大概的区间
你这样才可以估出来说这家公司
他的股价大概合理的区间
会落在哪个位置
这个就是一个大家合理去估计的方法
再来观察法人跟动向
那今天是亮说
甚至很多股票
我看今天涨停了
甚至外资跟投信也没买
为什么因为是一字形跳空买不到
所以下礼拜筹码是关键
法人挥补的力道跟程度
再来 好
那我们来看一下
这个是记忆体嘛
记忆体我们常讲
其实基本面都没有变
这个是现货价
你可以发现
除了这个震荡比较大之外
其实大部分都还在往上涨
这是现货价 低润
然后内的也是一样
都还是在往上
好狗翘
所以整体包括像三星
昨天讲说记忆体会缺到2028年
所以记忆体不会说
这个6月基本面很好
然后7月突然基本面就大崩盘
也没有啊
其实这一波修正就是所谓
之前涨幅过大的乖离
还有就是杠杆过大的一个
去杠杆的一个过程
当然还有包括
像我们前面讲的
全面性的割韭菜
这也没办法
那有撑过去才有办法
迎接接下来的反弹
有撑过去
仔细看报价
对 那合约价的部分
第二季大概已经涨这么多
然后当然第三季还会涨
还会涨
其实虽然涨幅没有前一季那么大
但是其实基本上
合约价也都在涨
所以基本面是往上
这个没有问题
这个是今天的
记忆体相关的
全面大反攻
而且很多是
一開盤一字型跳空漲停
因為昨天海力是在美國掛牌
我看是漲17%多
那今天海力是在韓國的股票
更是一口氣漲了30%
那因為韓國跟日本比我們早開盤
所以大家看到
怎麼開這麼高
所以今天其實一開盤
都是幾乎一字型跳空漲停
所以今天是量縮
所以我今天早上看
有人在我FB問的時候
今天是到漲真的 漲假的
怎麼量是縮的
因為一字型跳空
不要說你買不到
連法人都不一定買得到
那我们来看一下
用刚刚那个方法
南亚科的目标价跟获利预估
今年大概50到60
50到60
那明年呢
差异性就比较大
对
保守版的可能大概估7、80块
乐观版的呢
有都是100以上
有到130
甚至凯基最乐观估到130
所以如果你用本利比去换算的话呢
其实现在本利比
整个记忆体
我们以南亚科为例
其实都不算高啦
甚至如果真的可以赚100块的话
它现在股价300、400块
其实本利比真的
对 三百六
对 这个股价
跟那样本利比去换算的话
其实都在十倍以下
都在十倍以下
那当然有人说
你这个波动这么大的一个
这个所谓的
用本利比去算会不会不合理
那因为他们现在都说
我签长约嘛
所以他们的获利会比较稳定一些
好 这是一个
再来
我们看一下股价
那当然破季线之后呢
昨天其实震荡非常大
有急拉然后又急杀
那今天没辆原因是
一字形跳风涨停
那接下来就看先站回月季线的这个位置
好 那利基电跟旺宏
因为中小型嘛
这一波中小型股都跌很惨
这个是腰斩了
对 腰斩
那当然股价呢
有现在年线这边支撑度
那一样先看它的反弹
那我想其实利基电今年其实
他们的这个业绩跟获利
它的一个改善的程度也蛮大的
甚至包括有什么
跟这个美光的合作啦
等等之类
所以我想这一波的反弹
对于中小型股来看的话
我们就持续观察
反而这个回补筹码的力道
好 一樣站在先買顆粒廠製造廠
對不對 對
因為再來成本拉高之後
模組廠拉貨的成本也會變高
好 然後見證一下
好不容易變成紅塊塊的
變動文件
下週有這些公司
全部都要出關了
對 那當然最近很多人
我看網路上很多人在討論說
這個所謂的警示
或者說關警幣的措施
漲的時候買不到也就算了
那跌的時候賣不掉 更慘
那特別是很多是融資買的
也就是說你本來已經想停損了可是過後都賣不掉最後賣掉的時候可能大盤剛好開始反轉甚至賣掉的時候是還要倒貼給券商錢
所以現在蠻多人在呼籲說
這個規矩能不能夠稍微有彈性一點
不管是這個上漲或下跌
因為其實現在針對很多監理的措施
電腦都非常發達
不一定要用這種方式
來去限制這個交易的流動性
這是一個
然後月跌幅基本上都是40% 50% 60%的一大堆
那当然今天也开始大反攻了
特别是有些个股上面
哇 福尔很多
只要筹码一松动
大盘一不好
其实杀的力道也是很大
好 那再来我们就一样举国序为例
好 因为它比较容易算
国序大概今年
大概普遍估20块左右
20块上下
那明年就稍微
大概保守版的是28 27
那比较积极版的就30块以上
那如果假设我们用一个
整数比较好算30块好了
30块
那之前漲到1220
其實本利比將近40倍
40倍
那你覺得合不合理
那你就要去觀察它
過去的這個歷史區間的本利比
所以為什麼這一波會殺這麼深
那當然它現在從這個1200
殺到500 600之後
其實本利比就變成是20倍了
那我如果以成長股來說的話
我覺得這個本利比
也比較相對合理
因為你剛剛看
如果南亞科今年跟明年
表示明年這個南亞科
可以賺100塊
那现在股价是300多块400块
那你明年赚30块
现在股价500块600块
那是不是这个中间
大家就会去想说
到底哪一个在现阶段比较划算
所以为什么这一波
这个被动元件会跌这么深的原因
就在这里
所以大家记住
不管做任何股票
你一定要去稍微估一下
他金明两年的获利
然后从历史的经验去找他
大概一个合理的区间在哪里
才不会说每次市场
最兴奋的时候去跳到最高
这个的话
有时候遇到大盘突然反转
他殺起來的也會讓人
然後殺到讓人不知所說
甚至無法去Covity之前賺的
有可能還變成倒賠
好 這邊也要請教報價天王
因為不管是被動文件或是記憶體
大家的印象裡面
還是有所謂的景氣循環的問題
所以現在這兩種產業
有擺脫景氣循環的能力了嗎
就要看它長約簽的程度
如果長約簽就代表
獲利是不會像以前波動那麼大
那這個產業
所以我個人是建議說
你也不要看有的券商
估到2028 2029
那太遠了
大概至少今年跟明年稍微看一下
那個本益比是不是在合理的區間
好 這邊非常謝謝幸福哥
謝謝
好 幸福哥是非常扎實的
基本面的信奉者
所以剛剛也提到了
這一波修正下來
如果大家先來覺得
稍微指紋要往上走
優先看算得出EPS
跟本益比的大型全值股
台積電 鴻海 國具
這類型的券商都有非常多的報告
您找起來很容易
也不要看太远
先明年的看一下
如果对于明年的
现在本益比区间已经非常合理的
这些一定都是非常安全的
而至于像记忆体
真的跌了非常多
像坐云霄飞车一样
可是以评价面来说
看到明年
大家的本益比都奇低无比
也许您还在担心
他们是不是景气循环股
所以星不可说
也要看一下他们签长约的状况
不要把长约觉得是把价格绑住
反而他把获利给定毛之后
它可以让它的景气循环变得比较温和
是可以赚到比较多的钱
这才容易让我们做评价哦
好 今天是一个很特殊的
星期五台股迎来了史上最大的涨点
也让大家应该这个周末感受到
资产回血会比较好过哦
不过来宾们都有提醒
不要因为一天就掉有心心
该卖的也不卖
该处理的也不处理
那选股上也不要太大胆
还是要符合您的风险原则哦
也希望今天理财大安秀
对您投资有帮助哦
下周再会了 拜拜
拜拜